Коли запитуєш:
«З чим асоціюється Харків?»,
раніше, ще років десять тому,
усі однозначно говорили:
«Ринок Барабашова».
Ну, я не бачу тут нічого поганого, але ок'ей:
Харків — купецьке місто,
має свої традиції...
Студентське місто так само було!
1920-ті майже не згадували,
але вони дають зовсім
інше уявлення про Харків —
як про місто неймовірних
можливостей і експериментів.
Ми не користуємося своїми ключами,
коли там живе резидент.
[чекають на відповідь]
По-моєму, потрібно діставати свої ключі.
Чим неймовірні 1920-ті для Харкова?
Вони зовсім змінюють уявлення про Харків.
Коли було націоналізовано все,
квартирне питання було
дуже гострим у Харкові.
Почали експериментувати
з будинками-комунами,
архітектура яких задає
певний стиль життя.
Це як жартують архітектори:
«Де ми вам побудуємо спальню,
там ви й будете спати».
— Заходьте, заходьте!
— А, ось так!
Ну, насправді ми з Іваном
знайомі ще з 1990-х, правда ж?
Коли ти з «Новою дегенерацією»
до нас приїжджав.
Дуже рада, що ти тепер у нас
тут місяць на резиденції живеш.
Для працівників підприємства
створювали такі будинки-комуни.
А письменники опинилися в ситуації,
коли вони мали допомогти собі самі.
І вони створили кооператив,
вони вирішили вкладати ці кошти,
які заробляють, у те,
щоб побудувати собі будинок
їхньої мрії, письменницької мрії.
Так і розпочалося будівництво.
Це був перший приклад «кохаузінгу»,
зараз дуже модний напрямок,
коли люди одного стилю життя
скидаються на те,
щоби побудувати собі
будинок своєї мрії.
Наприклад, велосипедисти —
будинок, там де неможливо
припаркуватись машиною,
але щоб зручно там
ставити велосипеди,
або з широкими коридорами,
їздити на цих велосипедах.
Ці квартири були фактично
кабінетами письменників,
тобто кабінетами для роботи,
це були фактично бібліотеки
і місця для проживання.
Безперечно, це було елітне житло,
як на той час.
Це відчуття, коли ти вселяєшся
в дуже комфортабельне житло.
Справді, ти можеш дозволити
собі хатню працівницю.
Ти можеш собі це дозволити,
бо в тебе дуже хороші гонорари.
Тебе друкують.
Чи було в них відчуття того,
що за три роки почнуться арешти,
і що за чотири роки, буквально після
арештів, одразу перші розстріли?
Я думаю, що ні.
Ну, слухай, тут вже не така й велика
відстань між двома резиденціями.
— Тільки були там...
— Десь 30 хвилин пішки.
Та ну, не 30, навіть менше.
Навіть трошки менше.
Ну, от вже з боку Римарської
підходимо до будинку «Саламандра».
До другої резиденції в меморіальній
квартирі Юрія Шевельова.
От уявляєте собі, 1915 рік —
яка це була елітка!
Фактично, це було найелітніше
житло в Харкові.
Шевельов — син офіцера
царської армії німецького походження.
У 1920-х роках раптом
відкриває для себе Україну.
Відкриває цей український Харків.
Розуміє, що ця «українськість» латентно
завжди була присутня в їхній родині.
Він через вистави Леся Курбаса,
через твори Лесі Українки...
Тобто він через європейську українську культуру
відкриває для себе українську культуру.
І обирає, як він пише,
свою ідентичність.
Тобто людина обрала свою
ідентичність — українець.
[англійською] Привіт!
Радий вас бачити!
— Юрій Шевельов! [на футболці]
— [англійською] Так, він у мене є.
[сміються]
Юрій Шевельов пише
колосальну роботу,
де фактично розбиває
теорію єдності трьох мов,
які походять від однієї мови.
Ця та робота, яка була неприйнятна
для Радянського Союзу,
який насаджував ідею братніх
народів, однієї колиски тощо.
Коли ми дізналися про те,
що продається квартира
Юрія Шевельова,
знаєте, це було чудом.
Коли Олександр Савчук перевидав уже
перший том спогадів Шевельова,
він знайшов фото Шевельова,
він знайшов додатковий
візуальний матеріал.
І, зокрема, план квартири Шевельова.
Звісно, що цей перший том взяв
почитати наш архітектор Сергій Кангеларі,
який відкрив, побачив цей план і сказав:
«Мені здається, що саме
ця квартира продається».
І ми потрапляємо в цю квартиру,
і чудеса тривають,
тому що в квартирі залишилось
майже все автентичне.
Ми якось видихнули і зрозуміли, що, мабуть,
пан Юрій «звідти» щось хоче від нас.
Посилає нам якісь сигнали.
І ми почали процес викупу
цієї квартири.
Туди одразу не можна було
запускати резидентів,
тому що все було у плачевному стані.
Вона була непридатна для житла.
Хоча це було нашим щастям,
бо збереглася вся автентика.
Ми запустили цю реставрацію,
цим займався Сергій Кангеларі.
Ідея була в тому, щоби максимально
залишити автентичний простір там,
де можна його залишити.
Там, де не можна його залишити,
включити сучасне, але включити так,
щоб одразу було зрозуміло,
що це прийшло вже ззовні,
що це — сучасне.
[англійською] Це немовірне
місце для резиденції,
[англійською] тому що тут збереглося
багато речей і панує атмосфера,
[англійською] як в ті роки,
це історичне місце.
[англійською] Треба балансувати між створенням
чогось нового і повагою до історії.
[англійською] Мій проєкт —
про архітектуру та рухи.
[англійською] Наприклад,
про архітектуру і танці.
[англійською] Я вже перебуваю
тут два тижні,
[англійською] а проєкт триватиме
близько місяця.
[англійською] Результатом проєкту
буде документальний фільм про танці.
[англійською] Я провів минулий тиждень,
досліджуючи архітектуру міста,
[англійською] яка мені подобається,
фотографував і намагався зрозуміти,
[англійською] як вона «рухається» тощо.
Літературні резиденції — це можливість
побути не туристом на три дні,
а пожити, зануритись в простір,
зануритись у певну атмосферу.
Це можливість заспокоїтись, вимкнути всі
гаджети і телефони, відключитися й писати.
Це можливість дізнатися про іншу
культуру і зануритися в неї,
не як сторонній спостерігач,
а як місцевий.
У «Слові» у квартирі Лісового
колись був дитячий садок.
Це, очевидно, нас надихнуло на те,
щоб запросити дитячих письменників.
У нас був Сашко Дерманський,
тепер там живе Іван Андрусяк.
Він пише для підлітків і для,
як він називає, «малявки-шмакадявки».
У квартиру Шевельова до нас
приїхав Джонатан Беншауль.
Це британський режисер,
який приїхав досліджувати
наш простір харківський через рух.
Я довго не могла зрозуміти,
чим він тут займається, якщо чесно,
аж до квартирника, поки він сам
не показав і не пояснив, що ж це буде.
Тому що для нас це зовсім
якісь нові підходи,
для нас це зовсім нова методологія,
нова методика і нове бачення.
І я думаю, що це теж дасть нам
якийсь інший погляд на нас самих,
те, що робить тут Джонатан.
[англійською] Зупинись тут.
[англійською] Ви бачите,
що тут не тільки його бажання,
[англійською] але також
питання геометрії.
[перекладають українською]
[англійською] Що утворюється лінія,
яка починається з підлоги,
[англійською] і йде набагато далі,
ніж моє тіло.
[перекладають українською]
[англійською] Для мене тут є
щось структурне і геометричне,
[англійською] що одразу провокує
думки про будівлю.
[перекладають українською]
[англійською] Дякую.
Харківська літературна
резиденція існує з 2018 року.
Ця резиденція започаткована
українською гілкою ПЕН.
Спочатку вона була орієнтована
тільки на українських письменників,
потім ми запропонували одному
закордонному автору приїхати.
Потім за цей місяць проживання
в Харкові кожен отримував те,
за чим він приїхав.
Принаймні, так вони писали
у своїх підсумкових есе.
Тим не менш, вже є твори,
вже є видані книжки,
де написано:
«На Харківській літературній резиденції».
Іноді так називають:
«суспільство з амнезією»,
коли ми забуваємо те,
що було вчора.
А як жити далі, якщо ти
не пам'ятаєш, що було вчора?
Це не просто відкриті
публічні культурні простори,
а ще зі своєю історією,
зі своєю пам'яттю,
дуже живою пам'яттю,
іноді непростою пам'яттю.
Це надзвичайно важливо
і для міста, і для країни.
Це свідчення того,
як ми ставимося до своєї пам'яті,
до свого минулого.